[Musique]
le métier de serveur serait-il en voie
d'extinction 120000 serveurs manquent à
l'appel dans nos établissements depuis
les derniers confinement et les
fermetures successives des restaurants
en france ils se font de plus en plus
rares
aujourd'hui j'ai trouvé des cuisines et
des plongeurs des barbades pourtant avec
la saison estivale qui arrivent et le
retour des touristes les patrons
cherchent désespérément des saisonniers
pour faire tourner leur restaurant face
à la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre rôle de
syndicat de l'hôtellerie-restauration
aurait décidé d'aller recruter son
personnel en tunisie pour pallier le
manque de personnel le gouvernement
pourrait faire venir en france de jeunes
tunisiens traduit deux cent mille postes
pourraient être proposées de l'autre
côté de la méditerranée alors pénurie
des serveurs en france le gouvernement
veut faire venir des tunisiens cet été
elle même favorable
mais moi et moi à la base c'est pour ça
que j'étais venu et de fil en aiguille
j'ai fait de la téloche
j'étais venu pour ça lund i would be qui
naquit oui non oui oui oui salon vous
non oui alors déjà si on en est là c'est
à cause du gouvernement parce que c'est
bien de fermer le restaurant pendant un
an mais l'a entretemps les gens se sont
barrés ils ont changé de vie ils ont
bien raison ensuite ce qui me gêne moi
c'est que si les français ne veulent pas
pourvoir pour certains ces postes c'est
parce qu'ils sont extrêmement mal payé
le smic dans la restauration il ya 1400
euros c'est des horaires très compliqué
midi et soir et donc quelque part on
veut faire venir les tunisiens comme si
eux accepteraient ces conditions comme
si un tunisien valait moins qu'un
français donc moi ça ça me gêne je pense
qu'il faut surtout revaloriser ces
métiers socialement et économiquement et
cdc des tunisiens dont c'est la
destination professionnelle guillaume
ils ont été formés leur message dans une
très bonne école académie en tunisie
s'ils peuvent trouver du boulot ici
c'est formidable évidemment il ya un
gros problème les salaires vont
augmenter de 16% mais ça ne suffit pas
le gros problème c'est le logement pour
les saisonniers ne veulent plus ils ne
veulent plus aller bosser dans la région
qui n'est pas la leur parce qu'ils
payent à l'employé la france qui gagne
là bas il en resterait voilà donc il
faut créer il faut créer des résidences
comme des résidences universitaires
attendre les saisonniers puisse avoir un
loyer des sens non mais on parle on
parle de 4000 postes qu'enfin quatre
mille tunisiens qui avait déjà dit oui
pour pour venir le contrat qui il aurait
proposé c'est une durée maximum de cinq
mois cinq mois maximum et maintenant on
dit aussi que le gouvernement marocain
serait intéressé il faut savoir qu'à la
base c'est les tunisiens qui ont ce
qu'ils ont appelé les français en leur
disant visiblement vous manquez de
demain nous on a des mains qui vient de
qui voudraient bien venir donc voilà
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont chez mirial
n'est pas d'accord moi je pense que le
gouvernement pourrait donner un coup de
pouce ou trouver une solution pour
justement parce que c'est vrai que
souvent et c'est d'un problème de
logement sur place quand vous voulez pas
raison de faire une saison à saint
tropez vous imaginez les prix des
maisons
donc je pense qu'il faudrait que le
gouvernement français réfléchissent à
une solution pour que ce soit des
français qui s'écaille qui trouve tout
qui pourvoit s'est placée
pour moi je veux bien me rendre ça mais
à chaque fois on entend toujours la même
chose l'état doit payer le gouvernement
doit payer mais n'oubliez pas que l'état
n'existe pas l'état c'est les français
que nous et les impôts le gouvernement
c'est les français qui paient donc un
moment donné moi j'y suis dans le métier
justement je lis voumard les restaurants
et je vois bien qu à 2000 euros les mecs
ne veulent plus les postes fabien parce
que pendant qu'on filme ans on leur a
fait voir qu'il y avait une vie le
week-end on leur a fait marquer c'était
bien de prendre le petit déjeuner avec
les enfants que c'était bien ne pas
travailler le samedi et dimanche pour
1600 euros aujourd'hui j'ai plein de
restaurateurs qui cherchent des mecs
pour venir travailler il leur propose
deux mille euros de 7 heures à 16h30
sans la coupure il ne trouve personne
les grands groupes ne trouve personne
même les grands groupe hippopotamus
buffalo tous ces grands groupes qu'on
qu'on a raison il ne trouve pas de
serveur et ne trouve pas de chef et ne
trouve rien pas de chef de rang
personnes pourquoi parce qu'ils veulent
plus faire ce métier là pour 1700 euros
alors je veux bien moi des coups de
pouce par s'ils n'écoutent plus par là
mais à chaque fois peut-être que la
priorité pour le gouvernement c'est de
mettre l'argent ailleurs là où vraiment
les gens en ont besoin plutôt que de
mettre à chaque fois des coups tous à
droite à gauche le gouvernement sait
nous faut pas oublier ça la nette de
l'état c'est bien d'être de l'état c'est
la dette des français savent qu'ils
n'ont pas la dette de l'état là c'est
parce qu'il va bien falloir quand même
qu'ils soient pourvus ainsi la tunisie
aux résolutions des gens et de nuit un
basset des gens d'autres pays veulent
venir faire le boulot que les français
veulent pas faire qu'est ce que tu veux
te disent qu'est ce que tu veux faire
face le problème s'est installé en
france c'est tout
il a raison c'est au patois narration et
la raison et c'est au patron
d'entreprise hébergée aussi leur
personnel de
massa trophée justement on parle de
saint tropez où il manque 45000
personnes carrément dans la région paca
en tout cas il ya une base sous marine à
l'entrée de saint tropez où il ya un
grand truc militaire qui a été qui vient
d'être vendue à des privés et ils vont
en faire des logements justement
c'est dans toute la france qui manque
d'essence n'est pas un problème dû à ça
prendrait à la saison mais à monaco
machin cannes c'est toute la france un
moment donné ce métier il a explosé il a
exploré pour le covin c'est le métier
qui a été le plus sanctionné avec les
boîtes de nuit n'oubliez pas qu'il y en
a eu lors ils ont payé le coc vide mars
trois mois ils ont été confinés les gens
se retourner travailler la restauration
c'est plus d'un an fait un an qu'on file
en attendant sadio changer de vie on a
tendance à oublier que les restaurants
ouverts en dernier les boîtes de nuit on
veut en dernier ces métiers là ils sont
métamorphosés et maintenant il faut
trouver d'autres solutions à 2000 balle
les mecs veulent pas y aller en est la
raison autant ce durant la pandémie
l'ont fait ils ont suivi la plupart des
formations bien donc du coup ils ont
plus envie de faire ce boulot l'assaut
pour 2000 battus peut faire chauffeur de
bus tu peux faire plein d'autres choses
et elle week-end chez toi que tes
enfants tu es tu travailles avec eux tu
les emmène à chaud tu vois tes potes les
mecs qui aurait lâché 2 heures du matin
et reprennent à 10 heures du matin ils
ont vu personne non pas de leurs gosses
on leur dit c'est 1007 banon est la
solution la solution c'est d'augmenter
les salaires c'est comme les services
aujourd'hui tous les livreurs sont
étrangers parce que les pauvres ils ont
besoin de travailler ils acceptent des
salaires de misère sauf que c'est là où
c'est hypocrite comme l'a dit gilles en
france les frais sont les mêmes pour
tout le monde les gens doivent se loger
se nourrir et payer un loyer etc la
solution c'est de respecter les gens
n'aillent arrive les gens non mais quand
même on voit un cd sérail frangié a
barrel payer les gens le bayonnais payer
les gens récemment saas et de
l'esclavagisme pour moi de dire aucun
français ne travaille pas on va faire
venir des tuyaux
césar est insupportable c'est il
travaille à vue de
giraldo non moi je trouve que rémois
raison malgré tout je me dis qu'il ya
quand même 2,2 millions de chômage de
chômeurs en france et il ya 270 mille
emplois à pourvoir dans l'hôtellerie la
restauration et je trouve que c'est à
cause du fait que les effectivement les
salaires sont trop bas et qu'il
formalise revaloriser les salaires mais
malgré tout moi j'ai l'impression que je
sais que c'est des métiers très dur mais
quand on est jeune on n'a pas forcément
une famille on n'a pas encore des
enfants et je me dis qu'il faut quand
même mieux aller bosser que recevoir le
rsa ou le chômage donc je trouve quand
même mais c'est quand même dix ans c'est
je trouve que c'est compliqué voilà mais
les mentalités ont évolué quand même
parce que moi il ya 30 ans quand j'ai
commencé à travailler dans tous les étés
ça a commencé il
ya 30 ans mais je me suis arrêté depuis
mes très vives jamais dit ou trente ans
après mais si vous voulez à l'époque on
travaillait tous on était tous
saisonniers ont travaillé tout l'été
pour se payer les études dans les
comptes ont travaillé je suis très
content aujourd'hui le plasma du maïs ça
c'était l'enfer à pau enfin la même
demande une remontée de files
séparées même moment à l'époque ton
loyer remettons assurent ils arrivèrent
c'était ton loyer c'était à 20% de ton
salaire 15% c'est vrai aujourd'hui un
moyen sûr et plus de 50% pas besoin de
rue de saint quentin ça n'est pas ça tu
te prenais pas
cité au chômage mais bien sûr ces
données mais aujourd'hui les jeunes ils
sont plus ambitieux que nous on l'était
non light rail pour de
40 ans je peux pas dire que c'est des
gravats la restauration j'y suis depuis
trente ans un métier je veux te dire que
c'est un métier qui est en train de
muter ce qu'aujourd'hui je moi quand
j'entends des mecs j'ai proposé 2000
bars à un mec il m'a dit je veux 2500
coupure de 8 heures du matin je me
répète jusqu'à 16 heures il m'a dit non
il est parti parce qu'il a dit patrons
qui veulent le réclamer au passé c'est
un métier qui en mutation à cause du
covin à l'origine bas en espagne ils ont
aucun problème et en italie z'ont pas et
dont les énoncés qui viennent bosser en
italie en espagne en italie par l heure
pas laisser palais nationaux qui me
gêne pas trop quand j'entends par
exemple bernard keller de critiquer les
jeunes d'aujourd'hui où mes enfants
alvin implicitement ben oui où vous
dites finalement ils préfèrent les aides
non non et celles annoncées sont dit
qu'est ce que tu as manqué
mais c'est pas ça mais aujourd'hui les
gens me dire ce que tu penses de lui
laisser tomber il va là son côté son
spectacle avec trop méchant non mais
franchement aujourd'hui les jeunes qui
galèrent
dans la restauration il ya même pas deux
jours de repos consécutifs puis ils ont
le droit de jean de repos consécutifs
ils ont le droit des salaires décents on
leur dit mais vous prenez n'importe quel
job non les jeunes d'aujourd'hui c'est
super dur enfin bon on va voir ce qu'on
pense était spectateur puisque on parle
d'arrivée le gouvernement faire venir
des tunisiens cet été où il ya 21 % vous
avez vu le père avait pas du tout
d'accord avec 78%
voilà et je pense que
le public il veut garder ses serveurs
qu'il avait avant mais du serveur qu'il
avait avant on leur a dit vous n'êtes
pas grand corps malade il a chanté pas
essentiel qu'on leur a dit vous êtes moi
essentiel a dit
non pendant un an on leur a dit dégagé
on n'a pas besoin de vous on fera sans
vous on fera la france fait ni quand il
est là maintenant il fallait lire au
verizon chacun gère cela mais la france
sait pas où j'allais soit vous dire que
la grogne aborder les eaux en a beaucoup
c'est pas comme les autres on en est
arrivé là voilà rien et maintenant on
pleure pour qu'ils reviennent en cours
en faire leur boulot ils ont dit bah
c'est vrai que du jour au lendemain on
peut nous fermer un an autant que
j'allais faire une formation et que
j'aille voir ailleurs c'est vrai qu'il
ya des gens et avoir plein de gens qui
me disent cyril est ce que tu peux dire
que les charges patronales en france en
pêche les patrons de payer comme à
l'étranger bien se pressent à voix haute
et c'est vrai que ça c'est vrai on a
parlé plein de fois c'est n'importe quoi
je ne sais pas c'était ça tue le travail
on est des champions du monde bien que
normande et les champions du monde de
l'halloween sur la société il n'y a pas
un pays au monde qui payent plus
d'impôts c'est bien sûr et que nous n'y
a pas un péno maintenant mais les chats
bien sûr ça on a tous envie moi patron
le premier jeu ça me rend fou de voir ce
qui retire aux salariés chaque mois
quand je fais les journal et le belge
manille mais c'est pas possible c'est
incroyable des fois de ces c'est
n'importe quoi 2005 alors tu donnes un
beau salaire tu es heureux le donner un
beau salaire la personne et tu vois que
derrière cci reilly reste plus rien
c'est assez insupportable et charges
patronales pour les tunisiens aussi non
mais non non ça le problème en fait
c'est un problème
un tunisien oui si tu dois donner 2005
un français ou un autre un français ou
un mec état nation c'est 5000 euros tu
vas arriver six terminaux ses 3000 kms à
10 salariés qu'à chaque fois tu à
gratter mille balles matelas gratter dix
mille euros c'est 1000 euros pour un
patron il est prend bien soin s'entend
bien on va bien sûr qu'il faille pas
pour la médecine qui paye pas pour un
homme arrête arrête avec ça arrête avec
ça reste avec ça je suis d'accord il ya
tout le système à revoir pour moi c'est
un modèle le système est à revoir
on en a pas assez parlé pendant les
élections je vous dis ils ont parlé de
tout alors l'immigration ces gens
parlent ils nous ont cassé diplômés avec
les migrations la fin mais c'est vrai à
gagner et ils parlaient que d'islam et
d'immigration ont géré les poules les
problèmes les plus importants ils en
parlaient pas non mais sans déconner
c'est insupportable je vous dis c'est
n'importe quoi ça ça c'est vraiment le
problème pour moi c'est un des problèmes
principaux il ya tout le système à
revoir et dans le pouvoir d'achat ils
ont jamais parlé de ça non c'est un truc
de vous j'ai vu partout c'est ça c'est
pas possible aujourd'hui les mecs
pourquoi ils ne veulent plus travailler
en france il va plus travailler et puis
pourquoi il ya des mecs qui travaille de
8 heures du matin à 19 heures le soir et
qui se retrouvent dans la merde ça c'est
pas possible qu'ils se disent voilà je
travaille tous les jours comme un chien
du lundi au vendredi ou parfois de lundi
au samedi et je suis je peux pas acheter
un jouet à mon fils c'est n'importe quoi
je suis désolé là il ya vraiment très
très gros problème mais pour moi il faut
vraiment augmenter les salaires partout
partout partout
bah oui mais il faut réduire les charges
patronales à la forcément mais c'est
vrai tu as ta réponse comment tu va
augmenter salers et en réduisant les
charges pas travail qu'elles tombent à
plat tout oui moi tu vas faire pour
monter dans la main et
l'argent l'argent ils le trouvent
parfois il ya des on trouve à des
mallettes magic 2 milliards je sais pas
d'où les trouve un moment bataille à 15
milliards pour c'est pas pour toi ben
voilà non mais n'importe valade est tué
de dire attendez c'est comme un carreau
cassé un si les cas c'est un moment tu
vois plus tard ou tu t'en fous c'est pas
de moi c'est le cas par cas
les pourboires faut jamais oublier oui
souvent sa double ou triple malsain bien
sûr mais bon les mecs compter sur sa
défense est encore dans les mots
blessent un toit c'est adoptent encore
dans le monde d'avant aujourd'hui
maintenant les gens c'est beaucoup de
carte bleue il ya plus je paie en
espèces et aux avants année j'en donne
est simple
maintenant tu le mets sur la carte et
même les pourboires c'est une
catastrophe même les pour ba sur deux -
en mylar exemple il faut faut arrêter
avec ça de penser que le mec qui va
doubler son salaire et on se dit que
c'est important les nommer il dit doublé
il ne doublera pas si tu veux rien du
tout à ça existe ça dépend du genre je
savais qu'ils allaient 20 balles pour la
voiture 30 bal pour la glace pour le
petit le bec avenue georges au sol qui
pointent qu'à 17 coûte 150 va le faire
mais lennon va mal un gars avec une
balade yade a même un gars qui passe là
bas pour ça qu'on
dit c'est ça bah oui c'est ça mais là on
parle pas de ceux-là c'est normal lui et
ma persévérance il va prendre un café et
vins l'avenue l'avenue je déclare c'est
génial c'est à dire sans proférer très
très bon c'est marrant j'ai vu jamais
mais jamais celle là tu dois y aller
c'est génial jamais c'est génial c'est
génial mais c'est vrai que moi c'est
celle avenue montaigne
après tu vas d'un tube à vannes il sait
pas si c'est vrai que maintenant les
voituriers ses 15 balles abba voiturier
faire tâche est la voiture
tu m'as tu m'as 15 fois voiturier tu
payes ta retraite c'est bon mais de la
merde pas tant mais les voituriers sans
déconner défaut alors énorme et moi j'ai
vu des baïnes de voiturier à saint
tropez jean rabasse de 30 balles 30 bal
sans rigoler le mec te prends ta voiture
et de points 30 bal frères jeudi mais
frère qu'est ce tu vas faire avec la
voiture
changer le moteur
souffrir 30 bal a malheureusement je
n'ai pas sur moi résultat j'ai dû aller
retirer voilà non mais c'est
insupportable insupportable cette liste
en général les gens et les cinq entre 5
et 8 euros au restaurant quand tu
descends pas c'est un mythe auront 10 et
10 pour certaines anecdotes j'étais au
restaurant à guillaume guillaume
généreux il à dessein pour moi et son
bar et j'ai failli faire demi-tour pour
les ramasser
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
déjà de l'argent ils sont déjà venus tu
peux te faire un aveu dix mois moi j'ai
fait demi tour
j'ai payé le voiturier
ça me brûle